the iPhone 11 isn't anything special it
doesn't offer an amazing screen thin
bezels or HDR video playback there's
still a slow charger in the box and the
battery life is good but not great but
with that said this is gonna be the best
selling phone in the States and for a
good reason
but what matters even more is a shift at
Apple that this phone represents but
more on that in just a bit along with
that I'll also share the biggest reason
why I think that everybody has been
waiting the upgrade should finally make
that jump and not wait for the iPhone 12
what does the average consumer want in a
smartphone
especially the average iPhone user let's
take my wife she wants a piece of
hardware that gets out of the way and
easily lets her do the things she needs
a fluid and stable operating system
packed with conveniences that work right
out of the box check a high quality
camera to capture everyday life some
cool blurry facts that work anywhere and
maybe even the occasional slow fee check
how about video recording that super
stable and an ultra-wide lens for those
times that you can't back up check
battery life that is so much ahead of
her old iPhones check and a fast charger
to quickly top off when she forgets to
charge your phone at night Chadd no nut
check how about a price tag that brings
this feature packed ultra powerful and
capable phone down to a level that most
average consumers can agree with check
I'll put it right out there there are
many Android phones to offer more bang
for the buck
killer features and specs in the iPhone
11 but to her and millions of other
people all of that doesn't matter
now those things matter to me but she
couldn't care less life and love and pro
is an almost perfect device for her and
if you're an iOS user chances are it
probably is for you too before I tell
you why you should upgrade this year
instead of next let me tell you about
our sponsor which is also perfect for
pretty much everyone privacy calm not
only will privacy calm give you $5.00
right now with no strings attached but
they'll also protect your privacy
completely free sign up a privacy calm
slash Mac stack and you can quickly
create virtual card numbers that are
locked to whatever merchant you shop at
so even if it's hacked they won't be
able to use them elsewhere you can even
make one-time use cards which are great
for single payments trials or for
sketchy sites and you can set a variety
of limits so you'll never be over built
the best part is there are no down
sights at all not only will their Chrome
extension autofill your payment info
it will even create a new card in less
time than it takes to even pull out your
wallet so save time protect your privacy
and get $5.00 within the next 30 seconds
by signing up a privacy Compaq stack or
by using the link down below people are
waiting longer than ever to upgrade
their phones and if you're considering
the iPhone 11 most likely you are -
that's why I'm glad that this year Apple
is doing things differently they're
giving us more value than ever and not
only in the price but also in the build
of this phone
last year the 10r had one gigabyte less
RAM than the 10s this year it's matching
with the same four gigabytes
last year they sneakily use a slower LTE
modem which resulted in people
complaining about speed this year it's a
gigabit modem another big surprise was
that the 10 ARS portrait mode didn't
work on anything but people this year
it's fixed a big one was a single lens
camera which if you have an older dual
camera iPhone that would make going to
the 10r a downgrade but now we have an
ultra wide which is more useful for most
people than a telephoto lens of course
we have the crazy powerful a 13 Bionic
which paired with Apple's long software
support means this phone can last you up
to five years and with these new
features Apple has dropped a price which
marks a major shift in their strategy by
finally stopping raising prices and
focusing more on value I also love that
the 11 offers 128 gigabytes of storage
for only $50 more I really wish we had
the option with the iPhone 11 Pro the
iPhone 11 is a complete package and the
best value in an iPhone in years or
maybe ever but the biggest reason I
think that you should upgrade now
instead of waiting for next year is that
I highly doubt that they will
drastically redesign the iPhone 12 next
year the 12th pro will definitely have a
new look but I think the Apple will
leave the major changes to the pros
while keeping the standard model the
same design just like they're doing with
the iPad and iPad pro so if you're
somebody that is waiting on a redesign
for the base model consider that as a
possibility so the iPhone 11 isn't a new
breakthrough device or a value bargain
but it is a great phone for those of you
who know you want an iPhone thank you
guys for watching click up here to
subscribe and down below to enable
notifications so you guys don't miss out
on future videos and if you want to see
our iPhone 11 Pro review you can do so
right over there this man Max and I will
see you in the next
[Music]